hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
actually right now i'm in wales i've
just been doing some business i've got a
property about 15 minutes that way
and apparently anthony david and james
who are all
on my academy and have done extremely
well i've got a development property 15
minutes down the road i've never seen it
they want me to come and see it they've
been really secret about it and they've
just completed and they've said for the
first time they're gonna let me come and
look around it so
no idea what to expect but i'm pretty
excited let's go find out
i think i'm in the right place it
reminds me of ribs for house this
entrance
i'm kind of expecting to suddenly see a
grand building
[Music]
my goodness this is
crazy what is this dirt path
i'm so excited about what this property
is
oh holy moly
oh this is awesome they've got them
set for castle
oh my goodness this is awesome
look at it man jeez
i can't believe they've actually i hope
oh that's their building
i can't see anything else around here
that is
absolutely awesome
look at that oh my goodness
i can't wait to see them what have they
bought
they've bought a frigging castle they
are hilarious
they remind me of me
i hope it makes good profit oh my
goodness
incredible
look at them
hello
boys the reason why you should call me
uh is
one of the only reasons we found this
project inside looking for stuff like
this
is by meeting you coming on the train oh
my god
so i really appreciate you making the
trip off here it's just
well
oh man they've all written a heartfelt
piece
about the academy you guys are freaking
beasts man buying this thing
oh good supportive and then we just go
for the full planning now
oh guys i'm so excited 1983 i had a fire
yeah so and then this is what it was
left like after the fight another
the guy that owned it moved away yeah
and then um so they couldn't find the
owner for a very long time and it
actually had squatters here they lived
here for seven years in this condition
yeah so the original steels up there
used to house glass all around there
it's a big glass atrium
so we're gonna reinstate that into this
area i can't lie
i just can't even visualize like i've
got
i'm a man with vision right but i can't
even like with at least with my castle
there's room yeah i can visualize so
it's here i'm just like it's just i'm at
a loss for words folks and it's ground
it's definitely it's a phenomenal
building
it's got solid plumbing though look at
that
right yep i mean to be honest i don't
think anything solid about this
it's not pointing it's not falling down
huh no it's no
it's basically as it is so it's great
too as is so in this
run-down condition so we can do what
effect we want with as long as we don't
touch the facade
you'll learn
so this here we don't have to reinstate
that
that's going to be a big glass wall
there yeah and then this will be
all have steals to support the apartment
so this would be more one of the grander
apartments than there's going to be in
the building
it's beautiful surroundings though i'm
going to guess shortly bear in mind no
one's told me anything
i didn't even know it was a castle right
i'm going to guess how much you paid for
it
yeah i'm going to guess how much it's
going to cost to do it i'm going to
guess what the gdv is
and i'm going to guess how you find that
singer okay
the last one's probably easiest for you
because you know us what other people's
money right
yeah what did you think it was gonna be
when i tell you what i thought it was
gonna be i thought it was gonna be
um i knew it was gonna be something
tasty
because you wouldn't have got me all the
way to wales um and said it's a surprise
and then post on social media
biggest project yeah so this is going to
be something today i thought it was
going to be like
um a country manor you know beautiful
i thought it was going to be more
impressive on the like
nice in the inside but i didn't expect
this like a derrill in the castle
oh beautiful surroundings as well you
know like clear day you can see the sea
all right you've got a beautiful break
on it stunning it'll be worth a fortune
when it's done so this is where the fire
started oh jesus
you know whether it's like old style and
then his new style
and then there's derek castle's style
saying ha ha wouldn't you like to do
something with this
if someone would have the courage the
money and the audacity
to actually buy castle and you guys like
well we were trying to buy samuel so
how about how many square feet is it
it's 19 000. just under 20 000. well
that's the actual building yeah
internal giant that's very big yeah uh
it's big isn't it we've got 2.3 acres
with it
all right we've got the bats and they've
out oh you've got bats as well
welcome to my problems nowhere near as
many as we we don't
actually think we've got bats so you
might have bats so you're gonna have to
get there we've had one ecology report
come back yeah we've got owls
it's so nice to be able to share
problems with people normally i'm like
who else can i call up and moan about my
bats in the roof of my castle
how many people can you say i own a
castle yeah two that's why
i've been very poor sorry
shang dang rang tank
absolutely fabulous how do you feel
david about this are you scared
no no you're not at all totally
comfortable comfortable yeah
okay yeah it's a lot of work but it's
yeah it's an awesome building
oh mate absolutely are you scared
no no the thing is we've um
we're taking it step by step like you
said we're not looking at this like
right this is everything this is all our
eggs into one basket we don't do this
we've lost it
this is a project that's going to take
some time of course and it's going to be
worth it in the long run and we'll take
it step by step work with the right
people around us and it'll just work out
slow and steady
exactly yeah and we can phase it and get
things done first
well yeah i know what james is going to
learn on this project james is going to
learn patience
yes because me and james are the same me
and james are like everything needs to
be done tomorrow
you know but when you're dealing with it
you know sometimes
you have to just go off you've got a
little bit yeah because it's impossible
to know how much it's going to cost
you have to just think you know what
what's my intuition saying get all the
facts get all the information
yeah so these these will become duplexes
then all of these
five rounds here well mate if you do
this in service accommodation
i'll definitely be staying here
how high is this like that
that's a high that's a high tower and
then this like that one where it can
come down
i want floor-to-ceiling glass there with
that that few
because that's that like you said just
where you can't see through the trees
there that
see no japanese not weed though no
japanese
we didn't copy you in the japanese it
does feel pretty solid
yeah it is the whole yeah it's that's
one of the saving grace of the building
it's
all right then it's time for me to guess
the figures yeah yeah
now i've seen everything all right so
what do you pay for it
i'm gonna hazard a guess i don't know
the area at all
that's my big disclaimer i'm gonna
hazard the guest that you paid about
half the million for it
not far off um you don't have to tell me
i wanna guess everything okay
um i'm gonna give you about about 500
grand for it
okay to build it out obviously it
depends on what you're going to do with
it
i'm going to guess the end value let me
think
i'm going to i want to say half a
million to buy it
3.5 to to to fix it up in total four mil
and i'm gonna say the gdv is gonna be
seven now okay
that's that that that's a guess right
yeah yes come on tell me what the
figures are
okay i actually think i'll end up being
right
i think your gdc is going to be more
than you think and i think your gdp is
going to be more than you think
if it's anything like my experience i
think you're right
all of us are kind of on the same page i
think you financed it
um just put poor people in
you know poor people in i don't know
whether you pulled joint venture
partners in or if you just borrowed
their money on a fixed return
i would imagine what have you done
so buying it's not the issue right
buying it saying 420.
i reckon to buy i reckon you poor people
in
i reckon that you've given them a
percentage of the profit
i reckon you're going to raise the
finance by getting planning
and then be worried about that after
you've got planning but to be honest if
you've got planning and you can prove
you've got planning you can show the gdp
i don't think you'll have a massive
issue getting finance for it especially
with your skills that you've got
even if it's a combination of private
investors and development finances
all the bill that come from the banks
development finance after planning
master tenders all that jazz um we
bought the thing in cash using
investors money uh a mix actually some
of it's on
short term fixed return finance yeah uh
the vast majority of it's on
share of the profit we so we offered
every share of the profit the reason
being is because
you know we wanted everybody to share in
this project with us so bear in mind we
raise finance without planning
without drawings yeah without tenders
yeah without valuations
yeah without anything it just clicks on
the back of well emails and phone calls
pretty much
yeah yeah but people will invest in you
because number one they trust you
yeah and then you've got other projects
going on it's not like okay it might be
your first time doing a castle
but you're experienced you've been
trained well
you know but number two is everyone
wants to be an owner in a castle right
so if you say like look worst cases it's
not going to make as much profit as we
thought but how you're going to be in on
the experience and stuff
here's a great thing as well and one of
the reasons why we're able to get
investment when we purchased it
the land value is worth more than what
we paid for it significantly more than
what we paid for it yeah so even if
it fails planning yeah it's not going
too good no you just sell it on an
auction again
exactly so each value
and you'll get someone buying it even if
you can't develop it you'll get someone
buying just to bank it
yeah it will it will get planning for
residential 100
because we'll get planning for essential
it might not get the planning we want
for residential
so that might be where we decide at that
point to sell it on a planning game
yeah everybody still wins at that point
yeah um you know and
and that's that'll be the the bit where
we get to that judgement bit of saying
right is it going to be worth building
it out
yeah or do we sell it now on a planning
game yeah there's like five different
exits for there
i can't see you're gonna i can't see
you're gonna lose on it though
personally
with the area you can literally see the
sea from outside it's in a good area
um i know i've got probably half an hour
away
which is buzzing even the hot
all through lockdown you could not book
a hotel
within 40 minute radius
and i know this is within a 40 minute
radius so if you're doing this as
service departments i think you'll fly a
castle service department with a c view
i mean come on i've already got
agreement in principle for people taking
him off this for three years the whole
entire
model yeah oh the whole thing i was
shocked when i came up and saw it i was
like
holy moly it's like the most impressive
development i've seen
and um have you seen rivers yeah well
it's more
it's more grand when you when you first
see it it's like you know i mean
it's it's it's just it's almost like
comparing apples and oranges
two very different buildings but it's
definitely one of a kind
proud of you bro yeah so if you go there
and then when you get there you'll see
it
like on the corner thank you if you want
to take that drive up there
so james tell me what what possessed you
to buy a castle
it was a bit crazy i'm always the kind
of guy who likes to wing it right i
think most people know me know that and
when i saw this i thought
that just seems too big yeah and i
always said like and you
always used to teach when we were
growing up like a teacher i've grown up
like you always used to say them at the
academy well you were still young you
were ideas yeah
yeah but when i if your dreams aren't
big enough yeah if
the dreams don't scare you they're not
big enough and for me when i looked at
this i went yeah this you know what
there's
there's an element of like nervousness
or fear in this let's take it on
yeah and i looked at it and went see if
this stacks
this ain't going to make me like 200
pound a month this is going to make
millions yeah and i looked today and i
said on day one i wanted to get into big
deal so when i saw it i was
i was attracted to it and it was never
like oh okay we're going to go we're
going to make money let's go and see if
it will
and kind of took it step by step but the
whole idea being that
yeah he's gonna make a lot of money in
the process and you know what i i always
say big deals and small deals
are both pretty much the same effort
maybe that's not 100 the case with a
castle
but still though you know i mean a lot
of people will spend it a couple years
on
on a project and they might the best
case would be they might make a hundred
grand
whereas here you know i know you're
expecting to make seven figures
yeah which is which is which is awesome
so what was the plan what's the journey
what's your responsibilities and
you know role within this so my job is
all around speaking to investors getting
the finance in place setting up joint
venture structures
tax structures all that kind of stuff
along with physically buying
the asset so site acquisition is
probably the best way to summon it up
and then when we get on the back end um
whether whether we refinance and rent or
sell it
off i'll deal with that as well
obviously keeping the investors happy in
between
yeah running the the board meeting and
stuff like that whilst anthony and david
crack on with
physically building it yeah well the the
buildings has
this amazing structure i can't wait to
bring it back to its former glory
because
it's substantially it's quite a solid
structure yet it's got no roof on it's
got no walls
no floors but as a structure it's
it's going to bring it bring it back to
its natural original
splendor but it's in such a fantastic
location yeah it's going to be an
awesome
demo i think as well like anthony this
isn't the only project you've got going
on you've got loads going on right now
you just bought a pub
you just about on friday to complete on
a piece of land that you build in what
14 houses yeah that's right you know i
mean would you have thought
three years ago that this would be the
case
no not at all and three years ago if you
just said to me oh you know in three
years time you're going to be buying a
pub to convert into apartments i'd have
been like
yeah i can't see it happening or to buy
a plot of land they're like that's
definitely not happening
to buy a castle no now you're talking
dreams it's just not happening at all so
to be in this situation is just unreal
you know to have the
skill and the ability to look at
something like this and to see what you
can do with it and assess it
uh it's just
gobsmacked it's like a fairy tale dream
come true it is it's like a fairy tale
what do you think david would you i know
you've been doing big deals for a long
time but like
yeah but again when i went to the crash
course you've totally changed everything
and
met yourself and met anthony and the
development it's gone so
so fast and so quick over the last 18
months
to get to this stage doing multiple
developments things like that for
ourselves
as individuals and not for other people
it's been it's fantastic
that's awesome i'm so proud of you guys
and i think it's great to be able to
share
um castle problems with people
because i'm sure you know it's honestly
i'm serious though like
for me there's not many people i can
call i can phone up and say like ah
i'm having this problem with bats in my
loft bats in my castle like what no one
can relate to that
but you know having having you guys now
as as people i can bounce ideas off and
talk to it's really it's a really good
thing
you know it's a great community and
there's not just you guys there's a
whole bunch of people now
doing doing development and stepping up
on the property side and i'm
i'm very very happy and fulfilled to see
it happening so
good job guys thank you proud awesome
yeah awesome thank you very much
tell me how it feels to i don't i was
going to have the keys to a castle but i
don't know whether there's a front door
yet
but how does it feel to own a castle
it's crazy it's crazy and the sense of
accomplishment you get i've
worked on this for so long yeah that's
what we found yesterday you know
that sense of accomplishment is is so
great when you've had to secure the
prize you've had to stretch to the joint
venture deals
you've got to put all the paperwork
together and then deal with solicitors
and now you own it it's yours no money
down
and potentially combat millions on it
fingers crossed if it goes to plan
but worst case i don't think you're
going to lose on it you're definitely
going to learn a lot
i'm hopefully going to make a lot well
that's what happened when i sold that
massive portfolio
like yes i got paid well but the
education i got from that was worth
way more than the fee that i took and i
i i do it all over again
just for the education and that's what
i'm expecting in a deal like this
another thing is i appreciate the card
man you know what what anthony said was
very nice and what david says very nice
i couldn't actually read what you said
so you might have to read it but it
might be sentimental anyway on camera
but i can read it maybe i can read it
but a little tip though i haven't
written anything for like four years
digital now i said thank you so much for
inviting
me down to the crash course three years
ago um i was far from the man i am today
and without property i genuinely
wouldn't be as happy
or as fulfilled i could never have
managed um i could never have imagined
how much my life would change
when i attended that course and thank
you so much for putting so much time and
effort into building the academy
and bringing in so many awesome people
it all starts at the crash course
respect brother i appreciate it so much
you're welcome and honestly
massive massive respect you know massive
respect for me and
anything you need along the way any way
i can help
give me a shout out be in touch man all
right have a good one pleasure man thank
you for coming thanks so much
okay i bought a castle my students buy a
castle
what [ __ ] what have i got to do next now
how am i going to lead the way now do i
have to buy an island or something
oh well but island if you buy that all
right
all right hey see you later
[Music]
you